you know i'm a [__] up guy you know
but i hustled i was a dif i had a good
time growing up you know like i really
really did i think
and i was going through rough patches
but i had a good [__] time
you know i go home i see even my friends
kids i have a friend dede [__] tough
as [__] when we were kids
i was like 15. he was like 13 beating up
man he was beating up [__] men
it was amazing dee dee can tell they
used to call him manchild i so i went
home and i met his kid this kid's a
little [__] weak too you know
daddy daddy it's cold though what the
[__] are you talking about
i mean your daddy used to drink out in
the [__] winter shirtless you know
what i'm saying
but even man like me and dede used to do
some crazy [__] there was this
gas station by my house putnam fuel when
i was like 15.
and the guy who worked the night shift
we used to go down and like buy waters
and [__]
was freaky freddy he was a different
type of [__] freak and uh we used to
just call him freaky freddy he was a
good looking dude
he was like maybe 160 but his wife was
like 320 she was like uh
she looked like honey boo boo's mother
just like that
and he would have to get a high to have
sex with her listen to this
i swear to god hysterical so he would
have to buy coke to [__] her right he
was with her for a long time and now she
didn't want to [__] him no more
unless he had coke so they lived on the
third floor this [__] up house
and there was such white trash they
would rent a jacuzzi for the night and
put in their living room and she would
put a bikini on and [__] and
oh my god it was [__] hysterical i'm
like 15 looking at this [__]
and her feet were yellow there was
something wrong with her like
she had diabetes or something it scared
me i would never look at a [__] feet
when i went over there
so he came up with a plan he's like you
guys gotta rob me
and i'll split the money with you and
i'm like that's a great idea
so he goes but you got to beat me up a
little bit you know what man i'm not a
tough guy like that if i'm maddie i can
fight you but just to smack you i can't
do that
so the first time i kind of bit-slapped
him a couple of times and kicked him in
the leg
and he went down but that night he's
like dawg you got to beat me up for the
cameras whatever the [__]
so the next time i brought didi down
there dude he didn't give a [__]
indeed he picked him up threw him
through the plate glass window hit him
with a chair
i'm like dede ralph no i'll [__] this
guy
[Laughter]
but his son was just you know so i don't
know what's going on i have no idea
until i had a child
i had a child like two years ago and i
started going on mingling with people
yeah i'm an old man but it still [__]
works [__]
that nut sack is still [__] full let
me tell you what really happened i had
knee surgery
and from drinking protein powder and
doing squats it revitalizes everything
in that [__]
it brings your dick back to 12 years old
and i'm saying
when you can't even lay on a carpet
remember guys are you laying on a carpet
and [__]
your face would get all red what do you
want for breakfast nothing
i was with my wife for 13 years nothing
happened knocked her up when i was 49
she's 46 so
put that in your pipe it's never [__]
over you understand me
it's never over ladies this thing works
for [__] ever don't
don't ever take a chance i took a chance
a long time she came in she's like you
knocked me up i'm like you're a [__]
i didn't [__] knock you out but when
13 years nothing ever i thought it was
the reefer but not god has a plan and
i'm saying
god wants you to have a baby don't give
a [__] if you smoke pot he'll throw a
little magic into your sperm
you start walking all weird for a day
like that high school jazz